[Music]
hey what is up guys on TV HD here and
the Samsung Galaxy s8 is everywhere and
it makes sense because not only does
Samsung have a massive marketing budget
to put this thing in front of your eyes
but it also happens to be a really great
phone so makes sense but that makes it
so easy to overlook LG g6 which is
another fantastic phone it's actually
LG's best phone ever it's kind of like
the James Harden regular-season when
Russell Westbrook just had like such a
high-profile MVP caliber regular-season
you did know that I thought I would get
analogy
well Golf has never been my sport
Marquez but you're right the Galaxy s8
is a tremendous smartphone but
smartphones are very personal things and
for some people the LG G 6 might be even
better this is true so let's get to it
I'm mister mobile and this is LG G 6 vs
galaxy s 8
so these are actually very similar
phones both flagship spoke
top-of-the-line Ford's offered by the
respective manufacturers but right off
the bat there have been some differences
that can have a really significant
effect on the user experience and it's
all these things put together that have
me leaning between these two towards the
Galaxy s8 first of all the s8 has a
better display in fact it is the best
display on any smartphone which is huge
it's an OLED so colors and contrast not
only pop more but have a wider available
range it's brighter and more visible
outdoors and it has even slightly higher
resolution coming in at a slightly
taller aspect ratio than the g6 now
let's not to say the g6 is display is
bad by any means but nothing quite
compares to the edge to edge curved
glass display on a Galaxy s8 right now
it's in a class of its own at this point
in a year and that gives it this
immersion factor it's often better for
watching videos playing games etc
because it lets you completely ignore
the edges and just watch the content the
black g6 is definitely not as bad with
this but obviously it doesn't quite melt
over the same way and reflections while
they are a pain in the butt to ignore on
video like this they don't feel nearly
as bad in real life so there's that
display advantage but then I just give
the general industrial design and
aesthetic award to the Galaxy s8 it is a
much more sleek polished feel than a
slightly more industrial looking g6 and
again g6 doesn't look bad at all but put
them side-by-side and the g6 kind of
looks more like a rough-draft while the
s8 looks like a final copy the rounded
edges and nearly seamless connection
between the glass and the front and back
and the metal sides makes it feel like
you're holding a smooth stone type of
thing while the g6 feels like a
traditional phone type of thing that
rhymed but overall I give the aesthetic
advantage to the Galaxy s8 and then
there's just the specs on paper so I did
say they're both flagships but again
when you see the higher resolution
display when you see the Snapdragon 835
versus Snapdragon 820 one you kinda have
to give the edge to the s8 again in this
category and then just from using it for
a while you notice a lot of little
things I prefer the headphone jack at
the bottom of the phone galaxy f8 does
that for me I prefer no carrier branding
anywhere on the back of any model Galaxy
s8 does that too and the GS 8 is just
the tiniest bit narrower and light
g6o the screen to body ratio is just
that tiny bit better it helps and
there's just a couple more features
packed into the software stuff like the
iris scanner and the first ever
front-facing camera with autofocus but
even with all these things there are
still reasons to consider getting a g6
for your own personal use over a Galaxy
s8 so for those reasons this is Michael
Fisher for mr. mobile thanks man can I
get some music real quick thank you so
all your points on the s8 are well taken
Marcus but the LT g6 has two huge wins
over the SA I think and a few smaller
ones too
the first big one is projected
durability the g6 is a chunkier phone
than the SI then easier to grip I think
but if you do drop it the g6 is also
more likely to take a hit gracefully at
least on paper it's certified compliant
with mil standard 810g and now that's
not always as rugged as it sounds and
manufacturers can game test results a
bunch of ways but LG has been good
enough to let everyone in on which lab
it employed to test the g6 as well as
which procedures it used for that
testing the g6 past 14 separate tests
including low temperature high
temperature temperature shock humidity
vibration solar radiation low pressure
sand and dust immersion rain and my
favorite salt fog
now Samsung will probably release a
Galaxy s8 active that meets the same
criteria it's done so for the past four
years but if it follows precedent
it'll be exclusive to AT&T and also
probably aesthetically challenged the
regular s8 can be dunked in water like
the g6 it meets the same IP standard but
if it came down to which of these I'd
rather take hiking on treacherous
terrain or braving the salt fog fog of
sirata for I'd take the g6 the other big
reason I might choose lg / Samsung the
camera not because the g6 always out
shoots the s8 each of these can take
some wonderful photos but because the g6
lets me double up that extra camera on
the LG is more than mere adornment it
packs a 125 degree lens that lets you
capture much more of a scene without
dealing with a clumsy panorama obviously
this kind of dramatic framing isn't
always what you want and that's why the
standard shooter is there as well
between the primary and wide-angle
cameras the g6 can capture photos and
video the s8 just can't
a couple less things before I throw it
back to you Marcus well the g6 is
display doesn't have the saturation or
contrast of the s8 the fact that it's an
LCD means it may be less susceptible to
burn in than Samsung's AMOLED also the
g6 totally wins on buttons no half
functional Bixby key to get confused
with the volume rocker and yes the g6 is
fingerprint sensor is way easier to feel
out than the SAS organ ammonite mer
okay let's kill the music thank you back
to you sir so at the end of the day it
turns out surprise surprise these are
both really good smartphones in their
own respective ways and you might have
been swayed by looking at the comments
section maybe people saying oh the
Galaxy S eights way better or the G 6
wipes the floor with the s8 its
underrated neither of those is
completely true these are both really
good options so that being said that
puts it entirely in your hands to pick
which one of these you'd spend your
money on it's your call so that is it
thank you for watching and of course
thanks to mr. mobile for his
contribution to this video you can see
his channel right here he does a whole
bunch of mobile related videos that are
fantastic and again if you have any
comments or questions feel free to leave
them below I'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace
[Music]